[Musique]
soyez le bienvenu monsieur le ministre
algérien des affaires étrangères
monsieur sabri boukadoum sur rtl merci
je vous remercie pour cette invitation
que j'accepte avec grand plaisir
merci à vous d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
laissez-moi commencer directement par
les questions car de nombreux dossiers
ont été évoqués sur la table de
discussion algéro-russe quel point
important ont résulté des discussions
avec la partie russe
il y en a beaucoup nous avons d'abord
évoqué les relations entre les deux pays
dans plusieurs domaines comme vous le
savez les relations qui nous unissent
sont très ancienne elle date de bien
avant l'indépendance de l'algérie au
sujet de la situation actuelle et au
niveau international
nous avons évoqué les nombreuses
questions qui intéressent les deux pays
dans la région nord africaine comme à
travers le monde
des dossiers qui concernent plusieurs
partis notamment les nations unies et
autour desquels des concertations se
tiennent constamment entre l'algérie et
la russie
et personnellement entre moi et monsieur
sergueï lavrov
hu ceci est une simple mais aussi une
importante étape
vous dites que vous avez évoqué de
nombreux dossiers la question libyenne a
sans doute été à la tête de ces dossiers
et surtout que l'algérie a intensifié
ses activités diplomatiques sur le sujet
son approche pour le règlement de la
crise en libye est très similaire avec
la vision russe notamment pour
privilégier la solution politique loin
de la solution militaire
quelle est la nouvelle initiative je
voudrais savoir monsieur le ministre ce
dont a parlé le président de la
république algérienne
abdelmadjid tebboune concernant la
diversité des initiatives dont la
dernière est peut-être la déclaration du
caire effectivement la proche algérienne
pour le règlement de la crise en libye
est connue et nous insistons à chaque
fois sur cette approche avec tous les
partenaires de par le monde
et à ce jour aucun ne s'y est opposé
elle repose sur la solution politique
nous sommes déterminés à convaincre tous
les partenaires tous les belligérants et
toutes les parties concernées par le
dossier libyen de la nécessité d'une
solution politique en libye fait filer
bien ceci est la proche algérienne elle
n'est pas en compétition avec les autres
initiatives dès lors qu'elles ne
viennent pas en contradiction avec les
principes de la conférence de berlin à
laquelle avaient pris part l'algérie
ainsi que toutes les parties concernées
à 2 les hommes
à ce jour aucune de ces dernières n'a
porté préjudice à la proche où la vision
algérienne concernant le règlement de la
crise en libye fait les biens et
j'ajoute que l'algérie insiste pour
rester neutres vis-à-vis des différentes
parties libyennes concernées par le
conflit actuel nous pensons qu'il existe
une réelle est disponible possibilités
de rapprochement des points de vue en
rejetant tout langage armée en libye
yat-il peut-être des idées pour abriter
des négociations prochaine l'algérie est
disponible pour abriter des négociations
entre les parties libyennes
nous sommes et nous avons toujours été
en contact continu avec toutes les
parties libyennes concernées y compris
avec celles qui ne sont pas apparentes
la question libyenne se limite pour
certains pays à benghazi et tripoli
[Musique]
j'étais toutefois la libye est beaucoup
plus vaste
en ce qui nous concerne c'est grâce aux
relations familiales tribales et
frontalière qui nous unissent avec tous
les libyens d'ailleurs ils sont souvent
d'origine algérienne ou entretiennent
des liens forts récents ou historiques
avec l'algérie dans le même contexte
monsieur le ministre le président de la
république algérienne a parlé de la
dangerosité de l'armement des tribus où
résident exactement ce danger le danger
est qu à ce jour ces tribus ne sont pas
intervenus en tant que tribus le danger
réside dans la multiplication de ces
dernières mostar fait il se peut que si
on ne les défend pas si on ne leur donne
pas l'espoir d'un avenir pacifique dans
un état fédéré respectable et pleinement
souverain
ces tribus prennent les choses d'une
manière que nous ne souhaitons pas
l'absence de l'état et de ses services
dans certaines régions de la libye va
générer un sentiment de marginalisation
et de menaces au sein des tribus ce que
nous ne désirons pas nous avons mis en
garde tous ceux qui ont voulu agir
contre ce problème car c'était un
facteur de risque pour l'avenir libyen
certains ont traduit ces déclarations
comme des contradictions entre les
positions des pays du voisinage libyen
en particulier que le président algérien
a parlé d'une solution algéro tunisienne
y at il vraiment des oppositions dans le
point de vue des pays voisins
il ya un rapprochement comme un des
points de vue entre l'algérie et la
tunisie est relativement avec l'egypte
tu as des as tu nous avons conscience
des défis et des menaces induits par la
situation qui prévaut dans ce pays sur
la sécurité nationale de tous les pays
du voisinage y compris l'algérie allait
bien comme vous le savez nous partageons
avec la libye 1000 km de frontière -
avec la tunisie et les relations
familiales et tribale entre les deux
parties nous impose d'avoir un regard
particulier vis-à-vis de la libye
[Musique]
diaw l'algérie oeuvre en faveur de la
dynamisation du mécanisme des trois pays
du voisinage direct algérie tunisie
egypte et celui du grand voisinage en
l'occurrence le tchad le niger et le
soudan et même avec le mali même s'il
n'est pas en voisin direct la crise
libyenne a aggravé la situation au mali
c'est pour ça que nous partageons et
nous voulons nous associer au pays du
grand et petit voisinage qui ont
contribué au soutien de la prochaine
j'ai rien elle repose sur trois
principes la solution pacifique en
rejetant la solution militaire
le cessez le feu et le lancement de
négociations avec le refus de toute
ingérence étrangère
l'arrêt de l'afflux des armes ainsi que
le respect de l'embargo sur les armes en
libye
nous allons revenir sur ce point mais
parmi les principes qui fondent la
proche algérienne
nous avons aussi la préservation de
l'unité territoriale de la libye alors
que ce qui interpelle dans le discours
de ceux qui soutiennent les parties en
conflit en libye c'est l'insistance sur
les lignes syrte et al joufra est ce que
l'algérie fois une volonté de division
de la libye
et que propose-t-elle pour lui éviter ce
scénario on sait ronald nous sommes
déterminés à convaincre toutes les
parties libyennes de l'importance de
préserver l'intégrité territoriale de la
libye et la pleine souveraineté des
libyens en les exhortant à faire preuve
de vigilance à l'égard de certains
comportements qui risquerait de mener
volontairement ou pas à la division de
la libye nous a dit vous avez parlé de
la ligne syrte et al jafra dans
l'histoire contemporaine de la libye
nous avons remarqué l'année dernière un
déplacement de cette ligne jusqu'à
atteindre tripoli
nabli a tari nous appelons les parties
libyennes à s'éloigner du langage des
armes et revenir à la table des
négociations
et quand nous échangeons avec les
parties en libye nous constatons
qu'elles sont convaincus par cette
solution et insiste sur son adoption
et au moins elle le disait aux amours
tanner rhône bb avec won 0 nadal a
calqué maintenant il faut que nous les
persuasion de passer à l'acte et d'aller
de l'avant dans ce sens
vous avez parlé des conclusions de la
conférence de berlin dont la plus
importante est l'embargo sur les armes
en libye
mais après cela nous avons vu un échange
d'accusations sur le sujet comment
évaluez-vous le respect de ce point
précis les conclusions en libye je ne
rentrerai pas dans les détails mais
l'organisation des nations unies a
établi de nombreux rapports les
conclusions de la conférence de berlin
qui ont été adoptées par le conseil de
sécurité de l'organisation des nations
unies ont été votés par 15 pays
participants
elle impose l'application d'un embargo
sur les armes en libye
malheureusement certains n'ont à ce jour
pas respecter cette décision
ce qui va compliquer davantage les
choses vous avez évoqué la neutralité de
l'algérie vis-à-vis des parties en
conflit en libye qu'en est il des
acteurs extérieurs qui les soutiennent
pendant se positionne algérie nous
entretenons des discussions avec toutes
les parties qui ont des intérêts en
libye est évidemment celles qui sont
intéressées par la libye je comprends
qu'il puisse y avoir des intérêts de
sécurité nationale comme c'est le cas
pour la tunisie l'algérie l'egypte le
niger le tchad
tous sont des états menacés je le dis et
je le répète en ce qui concerne
l'algérie la libye est une extension de
l'algérie et vice versa toute atteinte à
l'encontre de la libye touché l'algérie
d'où notre refus catégorique de ce genre
d' atteinte aujourd'hui ou à l'avenir
c'est pour cela que nous exhortons tous
les acteurs influents soutenant les
parties au conflit à renoncer à ces
politiques et nous poursuivrons ces
actions dans ce cadre la preuve en est
ma présence aujourd'hui à moscou où le
dossier libyen était une priorité pour
les pourparlers parmi d'autres c'est là
une action diplomatique pas seulement
politiques dictées par la conviction de
l'algérie que l'établissement de la paix
et de la stabilité en libye est dans
l'intérêt de tous pour l'avenir en
parlant des actions diplomatiques je
voudrais revenir sur les déclarations du
président algérien que nombreux ont
qualifiée de franche et claire
concernant la question libyenne
je parle des déclarations qui ont été
faites il y à peu près trois jours
peut-on dire que l'algérie a renoncé à
la diplomatie silencieuse qui l'a
peut-être longtemps éloigné de beaucoup
de dossiers
il y a aujourd'hui une nouvelle algérie
avec le président abdelmadjid tebboune
il se peut que les flemme nous est
entouré de près ces dernières années il
faut donc que notre voix s'élèvent plus
que ce qu'elle a été dans le passé et ce
peu importe les conditions que nous
avons connus mais aujourd'hui la voix de
l'algérie est une voix qu'on cherche et
qu'on respecte la preuve en est par
exemple dans la relation qui nous unit
avec mon homologue sergueï lavrov
une relation de grand respect et de
soutien à l' approche et la vision
algérienne basée sur la solution
pacifique et politique et le rejet de
toute ingérence étrangère militaire soit
elle mercenaires ou autre il y à une
concordance par rapport à cette approche
à ce jour nous n'avons jamais rencontré
ne serait-ce qu'un refus ou une critique
lors des discussions avec les différents
partis l'algérie va reprendre ses
actions en vue des liens historiques et
du futur commun qu'ils unissent avec les
voisins libyens nous allons persévérer
dans ce sens et nous ne permettrons
aucune atteinte à la libye
félibien ceci est pour l'algérie une
question de sécurité nationale
vous avez dit une phrase importante la
voix de l'algérie va s'élever dans les
différentes organisations régionales et
internationales
cela m'amène à parler du rôle de la
ligue arabe particulièrement en ce qui
concerne la crise en libye
comment évaluez-vous son rôle et je
voudrais revenir aussi monsieur le
ministre sur une ancienne déclaration où
vous avez parlé de l'absence d'une
volonté politique pour la réforme de la
ligue arabe que vouliez-vous dire en
réalité la ligue arabe
et comme l'onu at il dit c'est une sorte
de résultat final une décision prise au
final par les pays membres de l'onu de
l'union africaine ou autre organisation
il est de même pour la ligue arabe était
pas tant qu'il y a une grande disparité
entre les membres de la ligue arabe au
sujet du dossier libyen entre autres et
en l'absence de consensus
la ligue arabe restent les bras croisés
et ne saura s'acquitter de son rôle
habituel
j'ajoute à côté qu'il est impératif
d'avoir une vision future de la ligue
arabe
[Musique]
nous revendiquons et nous insistons
toujours sur le dossier de la réforme de
la ligue arabe et souhaitons qu'il fasse
l'objet d'un consensus pour protéger la
sécurité nationale de tous les paysages
tous les pays y compris alors que tout
le monde attendait le sommet arabe que
devait abriter l'algérie nous étions
prêts et nous sommes toujours prêts
disposés à organiser le sommet arabe et
nous étudierons la possibilité de le
tenir en fonction de l'évolution de la
situation épidémiologique pour ce qui
est de la réforme
c'est un vieux dossier qui a été évoquée
depuis fort longtemps
hamouma
la dernière en date remonte à 2005 lors
du sommet d'alger
mais malheureusement il n'y a pas eu de
consensus sur cette question
la belle et elle a fait comme ça et là
sa flamme notre position par rapport à
la syrie est connue nous avons toujours
soutenu que la place de la syrie réside
au sein de la famille arabe mais il faut
y travailler
cela impose un consensus et des actions
dans les coulisses afin de convaincre
ceux qui hésitent toujours sur le retour
de tous les membres de la famille là il
nous reste beaucoup de travail à faire
dans ce sens mais la position de
l'algérie est claire nous tenons au
retour de tous les pays arabes
et rejetons toute idée de renvoi et
comme vous le savez la politique de
l'algérie reconnaît les états non les
gouvernements et les gouvernements
relève de la volonté des peuples qui les
élisent
on ne peut pas choisir des représentants
mais ont choisi la syrie l'algérie la
tunisie la libye et seul le peuple
décide de qui de représente
il ya clairement une grande concordance
politique entre moscou et alger loin de
la politique
yat-il d'éventuels projets de
coopération dans d'autres domaines que
vous avez peut être évoqué lors de votre
rencontre avec le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères sergueï lavrov
en effet la coopération algéro russe
concernent plusieurs domaines et ce
depuis bien avant l'indépendance
ce n'est ni une nouveauté ni une affaire
de coulisses oui nous sommes dans la
nécessité de la renforcer dans tous les
domaines et avec l'ensemble des
partenaires pas seulement la russie qui
a été importante
les et le restera pour notre politique
étrangère
les présidents des deux pays poutine
était boon ont eu un échange
téléphonique il y a quelques jours nous
avons aussi enregistré lors de cette
pandémie l'arrivée d'un avion russe dead
sur alger comment ces échanges
contribue-t-il au renforcement des
relations entre les deux pays
la relation qui lie les deux pays est
très forte
c'est une relation historique capable
d'être renforcé encore plus et ce dans
différents domaines je le répète il y a
eu un appel téléphonique mais pas que
une rencontre a réuni vladimir poutine
avec abdel madjid tebboune dans le cadre
de la conférence de berlin sur la libye
les deux présidents se sont mis d'accord
sur plusieurs points notamment ma visite
à moscou aujourd'hui je voudrais vous
interroger sur ce que peut apporter à
l'algérie cette ouverture sur la russie
d'un côté et sur la chine de l'autre
monde fatah l'algérie est ouverte sur
tous ceux qui souhaiterait établir un
partenariat respectueux et en échange
gagnant gagnant comme le traduisent nos
relations avec la russie la chine ou
comme avec d'autres pays un échange
mutuel dans le travail désintéressé
au sujet de ses partenariats je voudrais
savoir si ce genre de partenariat avec
la russie la chine et les autres pays
est la principale cause de certaines
tensions qui surgissent parfois sur les
relations algéro françaises où il y
aurait-il d'autres dossiers plus lourd
non jamais
il n'y a aucun lien là les relations
entre l'algérie et la france ont leurs
spécificités et leurs caractéristiques
qui sont bien connus ce sont des
relations spéciales historique de
mémoire ce qui est très important pour
les algériens il ya aussi une importante
communauté algérienne basée en france
la france est notre voisin la
méditerranée ne nous divisent pas mais
au contraire elle nous unit les
relations économiques sont fortes
nous voulons comme je le disais pour la
russie une relation de respect mutuel
le respect des entreprises des choix
politiques et de travailler ensemble au
niveau international là nous les douanes
[Musique]
nous le voulons et on essaye de régler
quelques problèmes qui nous entoure
qu'ils soient politiques ou autres
toujours dans le cadre des relations
algéro-françaises la france les pays
européens en général sont conscients du
rôle important que joue l'algérie dans
l'instauration de la sécurité dans les
pays du sahel et le sahara nous avons vu
l'algérie accueillir plusieurs
négociations dans ce domaine je voudrais
évoquer l'accord pour la paix et la
réconciliation au mali comment
évaluez-vous son avancement les seuls
en toute honnêteté il n'y a pas
d'alternative à cet accord nous
souhaitons que toutes ces clauses soient
mises en oeuvre par tous les partis
l'algérie est en contact permanent avec
l'ensemble des parties impliquées
notamment le gouvernement et les
organisations c'est emma et la
plateforme des mouvements du 14 juin
2014 d'alger et par permanence je veux
dire quotidien l'algérie président
jusqu'à ce jour les négociations pour la
mise en oeuvre de l'accord de bamako qui
a été conclue à alger et en dépit de
toutes les difficultés actuelles
notamment ce qui se passe depuis hier à
bamako
nous sommes déterminés à poursuivre
cette action car il n'y a pas
d'alternative
je souligne que toutes les parties
malienne font le même constat et des
problèmes prévalent actuellement au mali
conjoncturel j'espère que nous
avancerons espérant passer vers l'avenir
avec le consentement de toutes les
parties afin d'instaurer la sécurité et
le développement socio-économique au
mali la dernière question je vous pose
monsieur ministre concerne les relations
de l'algérie avec le voisin marocain qui
sont marqués de temps à autre par
quelques tensions
quel avenir pour les relations
algéro-marocaines l'avenir du grand
maghreb arabe et dans son unité
nous souhaitons que vous n'entendiez
jamais de l'algérie ou d'un responsable
algérien des propos inappropriés ou
déplacés à l'encontre du maroc
je ne rajoute rien les escalades
verbales les insultes et les injures
vous n'entendrez jamais de notre part
nous ne souhaitons que le meilleur pour
le maroc et aucun mal ne viendra de
l'algérie nous ne demandons que le
respect ce qui ne changera pas les
positions internationales de l'algérie
connue et acceptée par le monde y
compris le maroc
nous ne souhaitons que le meilleur pour
tous nos voisins merci beaucoup monsieur
le ministre algérien des affaires
étrangères sabri boukadoum pour cette
interview pour la chaîne arte nous vous
souhaitons une prochaine rencontre
peut-être à alger dans le cadre du
sommet arabe après la disparition de la
pandémie
merci merci à vous pour votre accueil
merci à vous chers téléspectateurs au
revoir
[Musique]